[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta Ecuador el
presidente Guillermo lasso había sido
convocado a comparecer ante la comisión
de la asamblea que Investiga un posible
entramado de corrupción en las empresas
públicas del sector eléctrico pero el
mandatario decidió no presentarse ya que
no estaba obligado por la ley lo que
generó nuevas tensiones con la oposición
esto se suma la atención política que
dejaron los resultados de las elecciones
en los que El Ejecutivo perdió el
referéndum para ampliar esta noticia
saludamos en Quito a nuestro
corresponsal Gustavo Ortega Gustavo muy
buenas noches cuéntenos Qué sucedió en
el parlamento esta mañana
Sí muy buenas noches la asamblea
nacional se reunió el día de hoy es que
la comisión ocasional que Investiga el
caso encuentro había convocado no solo
al presidente de la república sino a
distintos representantes de gobierno
para ofrecer así su versión voluntaria
en torno a una supuesta trama de
corrupción que señala a al cuñado de el
presidente Pero qué pasa el presidente
de la república envió un comunicado por
parte de la secretaría de la presidencia
donde aseguraba que por motivos de
agenda no asistiría a la asamblea
nacional por el cual No asistió al
parlamento pero la asamblea nacional de
igual forma también ha reaccionado el
presidente de la república no está
obligado a asistir en el parlamento y la
Constitución de este país solo obliga al
presidente de la república a asistir en
el asumir el poder de enfrentar así un
juicio político o de ofrecer un informe
a La Nación por el cual no está
inclusive obligado a asistir a ofrecer
una comparecencia en una comisión
especial Pero de igual forma la
oposición ha reaccionado y ha dicho que
más que una obligación legal el
presidente República tendría una
obligación moral para responder a los
Ecuatorianos si tiene o no tiene
relación o conocimiento de un supuesto
caso de trama de corrupción pero de qué
se habló en la asamblea nacional se
habló sobre un informe filtrado de la
Policía Nacional que fuera entregado por
parte de un medio digital donde se
entregó el día de hoy un 35.000
documentos en diferentes cajas negras
donde entre algunos puntos se habló de
supuestos vínculos de algunos
funcionarios del ejecutivo nacional a
través de intermedios con mafias el
narcotráfico también se habló de
supuestos financiamiento de bandas del
narcotráfico para financiamiento de
inclusive de campañas internas del
partido de gobierno y de campañas para
apoyar así la campaña electoral
presidencial también se habló de
supuestos favores políticos donde se
habría inclusive designado distintos
ministros y gerentes de empresas a
cambio de favores políticos y conexiones
con estas organizaciones narco
delictivas movida jornada parlamento a
Gustavo también se ha conocido que las
investigaciones del caso encuentro como
se le ha denominado este caso han
llegado hasta la presidencia de la
república Y eso ha generado decisiones
de los principales poderes del estado
acusándole de presunta intervención del
estado en la justicia A qué se deben
estas afirmaciones y por otro lado
cuéntenos Cuáles son los escenarios que
presenta la oposición para intentar
destituir al presidente de la república
bueno en principio se deben a que el
pasado viernes le funcionarios de la
fiscalía general del estado allanaron la
secretaría jurídica de la presidencia
ellos luego de esto fueron convocados a
abandonar la presidencia de la república
Y esto ha generado también coincide con
un procedimiento de rotación que
defiende El Ejecutivo nacional donde se
rotan a los funcionarios luego de
cumplir un tiempo específico de las
instituciones del estado esto ha
generado también una reacciones no solo
por parte de la fiscalía que habla de
intromisión por parte del Estado para
evitar así entorpecer entorpecer los
procesos de investigaciones De igual
forma también habla de intervención por
parte del Estado habla también de
acciones que habría tenido algunas en
instituciones El Ejecutivo nacional se
habla también la corte Nacional de
Justicia la asamblea nacional habría
rechazado esta decisión por parte del
ejecutivo nacional porque dicen que
estaría interviniendo en los procesos de
investigación y haría mucho más lento
estas investigaciones en la supuesta
trama de corru pero Cuáles son los
escenarios posibles que se comentan
ahora en Ecuador se habla de juicio
político en contra del presidente de la
república se habla de la revocatoria del
mandato también se habla de la
aplicación de la muerte Cruzada son los
escenarios que estarían analizando en la
asamblea nacional que estarían
ofreciendo una recomendación un informe
a partir del 23 de febrero